yes that's right so we were just
listening to rishi sunak now he is the
front runner in terms of endorsements
from mps but penny mordant
is in solid second place here
she now has the backing of 25 publicly
25 mps but she has just
been given a very big endorsement from a
very big beast in the party former
cabinet minister senior mp david davis
who joins me now to explain
why he is back in penny so david um
thanks for joining us on sky news so why
did you take this decision well i've
been saying for days as i've been
thinking through the process what do we
need we need high integrity we can't
afford any more scandals after the last
two years she's a woman of incredible
integrity i've known her for years as a
minister we need high competence got
really difficult problems coming on the
economic front and other fronts too and
she's formidably competent i serve with
as a cabinet minister at the great
showdown at checkers she was both brave
she was on the brexit side and she was
the most effective person taking pla
taking part she's fantastic in the house
of commons if anybody wants to watch her
take on angela rayner they should look
on youtube it's an amazing performance
but most of all she's got a vision for
britain she's a patriot she's you know
she she knows what she wants to uh to
put across she knows what sort of
conservatism she stands for and as a
result she's popular in scotland she's
popular in the wall so she's popular
with the younger voters and actually
she's the person who's most likely
within the party to to actually beat
rishi sunak so it's a it's a formidable
combination okay likely to beat rishi
sunuk and let me just just bring that
back to you because just what you were
saying about there's nothing in her
closet that could in any way disrupt a
bid from her just interviewed where she
was asked where she sounded like a
question at his launch raising issues
around his wife's former non-dom status
that has been obviously she's become
domiciled here now but do you think that
rishi sunak has things in his locker if
you like
that could prove difficult for the party
if they elect him prime minister that
these issues around character won't go
away with boris johnson if rishi sunax
put in place i have no idea about about
rishi's
backdrop if you like his backstory
whatever it is or indeed any of the
others but what we need to do is to be
very clear that whoever we pick you know
is able to present themselves to the
public with no prospect of scandal and
i'm sure that's the case uh with uh my
candidate the others they've got to make
their own case so do you think david
davis just to be clear you think that
some of the other candidates have the
propensity for scandal and that worries
you well what worries me we've had all
sorts of allegations flying around now
they may all be false they may all be
false but the candidates have to deal
with them all i'm saying about penny i
mean i've known penny for a long time
and you know she and i have very similar
views on what's what propriety means in
politics about what it means about
funding what it means about behavior and
what i can say is she's a very very
upright candidate and i think you'll see
that in some of the speeches in the
coming days david davis uh penny maldon
has been if you like a dark horse in
this racing that she's kept very much
under the radar she hasn't made any
public uh intervention she hasn't done
any interviews
but she's placed number two and she is
the most popular candidate as
conservative home that the grassroots
member website did a a survey
she was the most popular candidate but
what appears to be happening now you can
see it playing out in front of our eyes
is that liz truss looks like she is
becoming uh the one that could end up
taking on rishi sunak
in a runoff because she's getting the
backing of boris johnson loyalists we've
had jacob reese moss this morning nadine
doris james cleverley i mean this is
going to be a battle between mordent and
trust isn't it to get into the final two
well of course it's a batman all of them
i mean i don't know how many are still
in one or two have dropped out this
morning i think but but it's a battle
between all of them and the
party in parliament will look at a
number of things it'll look at is this a
clean break
from what we've just passed through
that's really important and ethics and
integrity matter right at the top of
that tree you can't you can't sidestep
that issue then is it a clean break in
terms of competence you know this is
this we've had a government which has
got us into an economic situation which
is not very good negative growth
high inflation difficult problems to
solve
is it a competence in terms of able to
get a passport are able to
able to get a get a gps appointment we
want a government with grip which means
the person who runs it has got to have
grip he's got to have the real skills
trust was is
she's in one of the great four offices
of state she has a grip why would what
would you say to those mps that are
looking at this and saying rishi sanak
is not for me who do i go for penny or
liz
why would you pick penny over liz well
you've listed some of the reasons her
appeal to the population at large but
also she's been so you think liz
you you think liz might have a a bit of
a
a gap between appealing to the party but
then to the pub the wider public i mean
i think i think penny's got an advantage
in both areas but as i said i served
with her in cabinet for years
i saw her
both on her own issues she was defense
secretary at the time where she was
brilliant on her own issue but also on
the other issues she dealt with around
the cabinet we all talk about all issues
and she was the one who was incisive
clear had a grip